Guten Morgen Linos.
Guten Morgen Linus. Guten Morgen Tim.
Ich habe eine etwas belegte Stimme heute.
Ja äh was ist los, Schatz?
Naja.
Im kalten äh kalten Zug oder so gesessen.
Nee, ich habe im warmen Dresden gesessen und gequatscht, aber ich war auch schon vorher irgendwie total durchdiskutiert, unter anderem auch äh wegen unseres gemeinsamen Aufenthaltes in Köln auf der Siegind, wo sie auch viel zu quatschen gab.
Ja, unter anderem habe ich da mich mit konstant zu THS noch ein bisschen über den Staatstrojaner unterhalten,
ja, die haben ja dort einen Vortrag dazu gehalten und ähm,
Wir haben uns dann so ein bisschen über unsere Einschätzung zum notwendigen Niveau dieser Software unterhalten, weil ich ja beim, bei der letzten Sendung.
Vortrag gemacht, oder?
Sagte ich gerade.
Sagtest du das? Ich bin noch nicht,
noch nicht so ganz da.
Wir haben uns ein bisschen darüber unterhalten, dass ich ja gestern gesagt habe, was man eigentlich, was ich eigentlich denke, was für Ansprüche an so einen äh Trojaner gehen, wenn man das ernsthaft betreiben möchte,
und dass man dafür eine ganze Menge Expertise braucht. Und äh konstant sagte dann eher so, ja komm, also so ein Trojaner, den hat man ja eigentlich relativ schnell gebaut. Äh,
mach dir mal irgendwie, lass mal die Kirche im Dorf, ne, ist ja jetzt keine keine Hexerei. Da hat sie äh absolut recht mit, ist nicht besonders schwer, einen ähm Trojaner zu bauen
ich denke das ist ein bisschen schwieriger ist, ist dann ein so zu bauen, dass man Infektionen auch unbemerkt ernsthaft aufrecht erhalten kann,
Also ohne irgendwie durch die gängigen ähm.
Tools entdeckt zu werden.
Tools entdeckt zu werden und sich irgendwie ein bisschen äh doof zu verhalten, aber auch da ist das Wissen natürlich noch relativ verbreitet. Es gibt äh Trojaner, die sich wirklich seit seit vielen Jahren sehr beständig eigentlich halten,
ähm man achtet da ein bisschen auf ähm Wandelbarkeit oder so, aber wie gesagt, es gibt Trojaner, die sind über viele Jahre erfolgreich,
Ähm das, was ich eigentlich als das äh als das Entscheidende sehe, ist eher so die Infektion. Ja, also irgendwie, wie kriege ich das Ding da jemals drauf? Diese, das sind ja die Sicherheitslücken, die immer wieder neu gefunden werden müssen, wenn es nicht welche sind, die nicht metigierbar sind, wovon es relativ wenige gibt.
Aber die gibt's natürlich auch, ne. Ähm Firewire ist irgendwie so ein so eine Problematik, ja, das sind eine Fire-Wire-Pod am Computer ermöglicht,
glaube ich nicht sinnvoll umgehbar, Zugriff direkt auf den Speicher, wodurch man dann Passwortsperren umgehen kann,
ähm ist mir jetzt keine ernstzunehmende Gegenmaßnahme bekannt, außer diesen komplett abzumachen oder auszuschalten,
eine eine der Problematiken, die so ein bisschen,
aber gegen die meisten Sicherheitszünden gibt's ja irgendwelche Abwehrmaßnahmen so, ne. Und ähm.
Aber grade also quasi man könnte sagen, so der der interessante Teil, den man immer weiterentwickeln muss, ist eher so der Infektionsweg. Weniger als die Software selber. Und ähm,
Hat äh Konstanz natürlich recht, dass äh wenn man jetzt irgendwie von staatlichen Behörden spricht, die machen halt irgendwie einen Hausbesuch, ja,
oder am Flughafen oder sonst was. Also und die können ja auch sehr gezielt vorgehen, das heißt, sie können irgendwie so machen und sind jetzt vielleicht gar nicht so darauf, äh, angewiesen
wir infizieren alle irgendwie zu fahren,
und dass deswegen in diesem Bereich vielleicht die Anforderungen doch nicht so hoch sind, wie ich sie ähm beim letzten Mal dargestellt habe. Ähm Fazit, ähm.
Ich würde sagen, äh also man muss trotzdem eben bedenken, das ist kein Produkt, das irgendwann fertig ist, sondern dauernd dauerhaft gepflegt werden muss von jemandem, der sich, der davon Ahnung hat, vor allem, wenn man betrachtet, was für ein,
Desaster eigentlich mit der Entdeckung einherging.
Als die ähm als der als der letzte Staatstrojaner, der von Digitalstar irgendwie vergeigt worden war, als der gefunden wurde, war ja gleichzeitig,
alle mit diesen Maschinen äh infizierten Trojanern theoretisch der Zugriff für alle Personen offen.
Und ähm für alle, die damit infiziert waren, die Möglichkeit gegeben, äh sich dieser Infektion zu entledigen.
Also weil der überall derselbe Kiefer wendet wurde.
Also der ganze Trojaner hat sich ja nicht besonders angestrengt sich sich irgendwie selber zu verstecken
und äh die der Kiefer den Command in Control Server war immer der gleiche, auch über mehrere Trojaner-Versionen und so. Also es war damit eigentlich das Wissen da, dass sich jeder dieses Dinges entledigen könnte,
und das ist natürlich ein Zustand, den du eigentlich nicht haben möchtest. Äh als als ähm Regierung,
Dann noch äh was ich noch dazu sagen muss, dass ich äh bei der letzten Sendung so sagte, ja äh die werden einfach zu jemanden gehen, der sich damit auskennt und das wäre unter meinem Wissen Gamma, ähm die Seite,
Planet Punkt Info, die ihr auf den Wiki Leaks äh Spyfiles beruht und von Andy da ähm hingesetzt wurde, listet aber irgendwie so zu ähm irgendwie fünf, vierzig,
oder auch zu äh Tactical Interception, wo dann so ähm Gamma irgendwie drunterfällt, auch da hast du noch ähm,
fünf, sechs Firmen. Also es ist nicht nur Gamma, die so etwas machen, ja. Ähm.
Und ich habe da so leichtfertig daher gesagt, ja, die werden sich, die werden sich das jetzt von Gamma holen. Das machen die. Ähm das war meine Prognose. Nicht eine Feststellung, dass das passiert. Ja, es muss also auch noch irgendwie äh festgestellt werden.
Also du bist der Meinung, das, wo du deine Meinung dann geteilt.
Die Meinung äh wurde insofern nicht geteilt, dass ähm gerade Gamma wegen, weil sie ja in Nordafrika auf diesen Rechnern gefunden wurden. Also da wurde diese diese Software Finn Fischer von der Regierung gegen die Bevölkerung eingesetzt,
Und dass damit einhergehende PR-Debakel das weiß wahrscheinlich selbst die Bundesregierung ähm zu vermeiden, wenn sie jetzt sagen würden, alles klar, wir nehmen genau diese Software. Also damit hätten sie äh,
Ja, das war so ein sehr, sehr wichtiger,
sehr wichtiger Hinweis von Konstanz, die jetzt sagte so, das mag sein, dass das die die schöne Software ist. Ich sagte ja dann, ja, äh ich ich stelle mir so eine Finn Fischer BRD Edition vor, also Finn Fischer.
Von führenden Diktatoren empfohlen.
Von führenden Diktatoren empfohlen, aber so eine BRD-Version, die halt irgendwie dann auf, auf, auf, auf deutsches Recht zugeschnitten ist, dafür das Doppelte kostet und die Hälfte kann
und da sagte Konstanze dann so, ja also sie rechnet nicht damit, dass wir als Gegner dieser Software den Hebel in die Hand gedrückt bekommen, dass sie wirklich von dem gleichen Hersteller kommt. Also auch da äh sehr erhellende äh Argumente von,
den Leuten, die sich da ähm.
Regelmäßig mit.
Mit großer Akquise sehr regelmäßig und sehr gut mit beschäftigen.
Also es bleibt spannend, ich vertrete trotzdem die These, dass das irgendwie outgesourct wird, weil äh also genau, sie hatten ja dann so, sind jetzt überhaupt bloß in der in diesem Vortrag erwähnte äh Konstanze dann nochmal diese ähm,
Diese Stellenausschreibung des BKA da hatte. Da hatten sie irgendwie so eine Liste mit Anforderungen, die war relativ lang. Also es war eine Liste an Anforderungen, wo die jetzt von der reinen Länge her äh etwas wertig gar nicht zu Ende lesen, weil ich weiß, die kann ich nicht alle erfüllen, wenn man dann aber.
Ist die veröffentlicht worden.
Du bist irgendwie so gemein, was soll das denn? Den Link kann ich da nachher reinmachen. Äh.
Äh ich mich interessiert das, ob die denn mittlerweile auch im Internet irgendwie äh.
Ja ja, die war, die war online. Ich glaube, sie ist es inzwischen nicht mehr. Ich.
Ja, okay, kann ja auch sein, dass es nur in unserem Amtsplatz steht oder so, was weiß ich.
Stellenanzeige.
Die Uhr musst du mir jetzt nicht sagen. Also im Internet. Das reicht heutzutage als Quellenangabe. Du weißt doch, wie es ist. Quelle Internet.
Internet. Also okay, war im Internet, ja. Ähm ich suche mal gerade, ob ich das irgendwo.
Hattest auf jeden Fall irgendwo. Also äh BKA hatte da so eine Stellenanzeige, hat eine relativ äh ausführliche
ein relativ ausführliches Anforderungsprofil gehabt, was man alles können sollte und ähm da drunter stand dann irgendwie so ein Tarifvertrag für den öffentlichen Dienst, äh
bissel Stufe dreizehn oder so, was Konstanze meinte, was dann irgendwie so zweitausendeinhundert Euro netto ähm,
Entsprechen würde, dann wurde irgendwie laut gelacht. Jetzt muss man natürlich überlegen, so ein Großteil der Bevölkerung verdient vielleicht tatsächlich nicht zweitausendeinhundert netto. Sie aber natürlich überlegen dafür, dass man dann ein Anforderungsprofil dieser Länge,
erfüllt, mit dem man locker irgendwie internationaler Star werden könnte, so ungefähr. Da macht man dann wahrscheinlich nicht den Schritt für zwei eins irgendwie die gesamte deutsche Bevölkerung. Ähm.
Wahrscheinlich schon eher der Tagessatz.
Ich denke da, also das ist wirklich jetzt kein besonders attraktives Angebot und ähm äh der die Vermutung liegt nahe, dass äh das BKA tatsächlich,
In dem Moment, wo sie diese Stellenanzeige äh geschaltet haben, konnte man eigentlich voraussehen, dass sie drei Monate später, wenn sich da eben,
Was weiß ich, nur irgendwie diejenigen, die irgendwie seit fünf Monaten auf Hartz vier sind und dann irgendwie Druck vom Amt bekommen, dass jetzt Bewerbungen schreiben müssen,
da mal irgendwie sowas hinschludern, ja. Aber dass man da jetzt im Zweifelsfall keinen finden würde, ähm war absehbar.
Ähm wie geht's weiter?
Genau, dann noch ein ganz kurzer, ganz kurzer äh Ausflug, weil wir weil ich bei der letzten Sendung so viel davon erzählt habe, was man alles mit Sicherheitslücken böses machen kann, an wem man sie alles verkaufen kann. Ähm es gibt natürlich auch,
sage ich mal, den redlichen Sicherheitsforscher. Ähm der sich häufig die Frage fallen lassen muss, warum macht ihr das überhaupt? Warum sucht ihr die? Ja? Ähm,
da gibt's natürlich verschiedene Motivationen. Also ich glaube, die Zentrale ist einfach, dass es Spaß macht, was eine intellektuelle Herausforderung ist,
es gibt natürlich auch irgendwie sowas wie Anerkennung in der Hackerszene, man möchte in der Regel auch einen positiven Effekt haben, nämlich dass diese ähm,
Sicherheitslücke geschlossen wird, ähm irgendwie Aufmerksamkeit, Fame, seinen eigenen Marktwert steigern, vielleicht äh auf dem Arbeitsmarkt ähm,
Aber die meisten Sicherheitsforscher haben ja schon ein sehr ausgeprägte soziale Verantwortlichkeit und wollen so eine große ähm,
so eine große Ausnutzung dieser Sicherheitslücke eigentlich verhindern. Und der Prozess, der sich da durchgesetzt hat, ist eben unter der Annahme, dass es auch immer andere können,
ähm ein Prozess. Das heißt, ich finde Sicherheitslücke a in Technologie X,
und informiere dann den Hersteller dieser Technologie. Völlig egal, ob das jetzt Open Source oder oder ist und sage, pass mal auf, dieses und jenes Problem habt ihr.
Und dann setzt man eine Frist,
Um einen Druck, also eine sinnvolle Frist, wann man diese Sicherheitslücke veröffentlicht oder die das Wissen über diese Sicherheitslücke veröffentlicht, um einen mäßigen Druck auf die Verantwortlichen auszuüben, sich dieses Problems anzunehmen,
Ähm das wird immer mal wieder, leider dann auch missverstanden als Erpressung.
Ähm aber zeigt's eigentlich, dass es der beste Kompromiss ist aus,
Betroffene zu schützen und gleichzeitig
Druck auszuüben, um eine schnelle äh Lösung des Konfliktes herbei, äh dieser, dieses, dieser Situation herbeizuführen. Es hat sich irgendwie die Erfahrung zeigt, wenn man das nicht damit verbindet zu sagen, übrigens Freunde,
in drei Monaten halte ich darüber einen Vortrag beim Kongress, dass dann vielleicht nicht ganz so sehr mit Hochdruck an der Beheerung der Sicherheitslücke.
Gearbeitet wird. Einige äh setzen auch auf die, also das so die Strategie,
Ähm und einige setzen auch immer mal wieder auf die,
da wir jetzt so als als klassisches Beispiel aus der letzten Zeit wahrscheinlich dieser WhatsApp-Catcher für Android zu nennen, das erschien mir eher so 'ne,
so 'ne Sache in dieser Richtung zu sein, wo man also eine die Sicherheitslücke komplett fertig ähm,
also zum direkten zur direkten Anwendung für jedermann äh in die Welt haut. Ohne dem ohne eventuell sogar den den Hersteller vorzuwarnen oder ihn nur sehr kurzfristig vorzuwarnen und ihm keine Gelegenheit zu geben,
die Lücke irgendwie zu patchen,
Ähm das wird häufig mit der äh mit der Annahme getan, dass durch dieses Veröffentlichen der Druck einfach noch höher ist und die Lücke noch schneller,
gefixt wird. Dahinter verbirgt sich, wie gesagt, immer implizit die Annahme, dass das, was ich herausgefunden habe, auch andere herausfinden können und die könnten böse sein.
Unter den Umständen äh unter der rationale wird dann entsprechend ähm gehandelt.
Und ähm was würdest du meinen, in welcher Verbreitung sich die beiden Methoden so befinden generell? Also was ist so das, was so vorherrscht.
Also vorherrscht. Da habe ich auch so drüber nachgedacht. Ich habe eigentlich den Eindruck, dass ähm.
Bei Disclosure, damit geht eigentlich einher, dass die ganze Sache wahrscheinlich nicht so große Wellen schlägt. Und ähm.
Ich glaube, dass eigentlich schon äh ein sehr großer Teil äh oder der größere Teil auf jeden Fall responsible Disclosure ist.
Fälle sind selten näher, ja. Also denken wir mal an, also du musst ja denken
Überlegen, wenn wenn du irgendwie so ein so ein mercOS Update kriegst, wo du dann deine zwanzig äh Remote Excel-Cusion, Abitur record Execution steht ja dann immer so schön da. Das sind ja Sicherheits äh Probleme, sage ich mal, der höchsten,
Ebene. Die hat Apple ja im Zweifelsfall nicht alle einfach nur selber vor sich hingesucht,
Da ist eher von auszugehen, dass da genau das passiert ist, dass einer sagt, hier Freunde, das und das habe ich gemacht und so kann man die Kiste infizieren und bitte tut mal was.
Ähm wie gesagt, der könnte dann eben auch sagen, wenn es so in einem halben Jahr veröffentliche ich das oder sonst was,
Das ist ein wird dann gerne mal missverstanden.
Und was man auch nicht machen sollte, ist dann irgendwie sehr klar zu verstehen geben, dass man übrigens gerade einen Job sucht oder so. Ähm diese Annahmen, also diese,
Idee ist natürlich im Prinzip natürlich schon mit dabei, dass man dass man quasi so ein Disclose auch als eine Bewerbung bei dem Unternehmen sehen kann ähm,
Wird aber von einigen äh Liegeabteilungen der Unternehmen dann auch mal ein bisschen äh anders wahrgenommen, weil die
häufig das Kommunikationsproblem haben, nicht zu verstehen, warum hat er überhaupt diese Sicherheitslücke gesucht? Was hat der gegen uns?
Die nicht wirklich verstehen, dass äh Hacker das einfach machen, weil es interessant ist, weil da ein schönes Puzzleteil liegt und weil einer gesagt hat, äh hier diese Kiste ist unknackbar und dass dann jeder denkt so, Mensch, da habe ich ja mal eine Herausforderung, da kann ich ja mal gucken.
Aber wie geht denn das Ganze jetzt einher mit ähm der Realität, dass ja viele Sicherheitslücken auch letztlich verkauft werden.
Das sind die Bösen. Also ähm na ja, das geht äh es geht genau damit einher, dass dass du bei diesem ganzen natürlich nicht unbedingt äh direktes Geld verdienst.
Ja und gibt's da keinen Mittelweg.
Ähm der Mittelweg, denke ich, ist und dass es das beobachtet man, sage ich mal, bei den bei den meisten Hackern ist wahrscheinlich sich durch.
Ähm sage ich mal, eine Reihe vernünftiger responsible Disclosures.
Einen gewissen Ruf aufzubauen, der nicht direkt, aber dadurch indirekt dazu führt, dass man als ähm.
Häufiger gebucht wird.
Als Experte häufiger gebucht wird in, in Beratungsverträge kommt oder sonstiges. Denke, das ist der ähm der lautere Weg, wie man sicher IT-Sicherheitsforschungsunternehmen betreibt.
Aber es gibt doch jetzt auch diesen Markt, wo Explods verkauft werden, also wo tatsächlich auch Geld genommen wird für Sicherheitslücken,
wer, also kaufen das dann auch nur die bösen, ja, also kaufen da die Bösen von den von den Bösen,
Von den bösen Blackheads oder gibt's auch tatsächlich Firmen, die sagen, äh bevor uns da irgendwas passiert, äh zahlen wir lieber hier die Extrastrafe und wissen Bescheid.
Ich habe noch nie einen Explode verkauft und also man muss sich auch diesen Markt nicht vorstellen, wie äh dass das jetzt ein Marktplatz ist,
wo Leute sich hinstellen, ne, also ähm dieses Beispiel, was ich letzte Mal hatte, das äh wupen, diese Firma, die quasi eigentlich die die guten Wettbewerbe nutzt, um Aufmerksamkeit auf sich zu generieren,
ähm also dieses, also jeder, der irgendwie einen Explod verkauft, ist natürlich relativ schweigsam darüber, dass er es überhaupt gemacht hat und an wen,
Insofern ist da relativ wenig belastbares zu sagen, wer kauft diese Dinger? Ähm eventuell ist es auch tatsächlich so, dass äh
selber, diese äh kaufen. Das würden sie aber äh im Zweifelsfall nicht zugeben, ja, weil ähm du würdest dich ja im Prinzip zum Affen machen, wenn rauskommt, dass du
deine eigenen für sehr viel Geld kaufst. Ähm andererseits kann es auch sehr gut sein oder oder deine eigenen Wahl-Rabilitys kaufst. Ähm.
Weiterhin kommen die ja so kommst du ja immer in diesen in diesen äh drei rein, dass das der,
man irgendwie von Erpressungen reden kann oder könnte. Ja, es ist schon häufiger auch vorgekommen, dass Hacker mit mit einem auf einmal irgendwie die Anwälte äh dranhängen hatten,
Und wenn das schon bei bei sage ich mal lauteren ähm Hacker so ist, dann ist das natürlich bei jemandem, der irgendwie Explodes verkauft, noch noch viel eher so,
es wird eher weniger beworben und ist ein sehr schwieriges Feld, wo man jetzt nicht so wirklich was,
zu sagen kann.
Dann würde ich sagen, belassen wir es auch erstmal äh dabei an alle Hacker da draußen geht auf jeden Fall der Hinweis
Ist vielleicht doch äh so weit äh stückweise eine Reputation aufbauen und dann langfristig davon zieren, als sich da in irgendein
Strudel einsaugen zu lassen.
Man hat vor allem den Vorteil, dass man äh nicht so sehr Angst vor Kriminellen haben muss,
ist ja auch schon vielen Leuten sehr schlecht damit gegangen ähm bestimmtes Wissen, das sie haben zu bekannt zu machen und dann irgendwie bestimmte Mafia oder so äh deren Interesse auf sich gelenkt haben.
Das ist glaube ich auch ein Grund, warum viele.
Nee, das ist auch nicht so der Schlagmensch, mit dem man besonders viel zu tun haben will. Definitiv nicht. Gut, kommen wir mal zu unseren äh sonstigen äh Themen hier, damit sie nicht immer nur um Sicherheit und äh das böse Einbrechen geht,
Was haben wir denn noch?
Verletzungen der Netzneutralität, auch eigentlich eine, na, das ist noch was mit Sicherheit zu tun, nein. Ähm, gab einen,
gab mal wieder eine Studie äh das ist eigentlich nur deshalb erwähnenswert, diese Studie hat nichts herausgefunden, was wir nicht vielleicht ohnehin schon,
wüssten,
nämlich das Netzneutralität massenhaft verletzt wird von Providern. Ähm das Schöne ist nur, dass sie jetzt eben eine Studie ist und wir wissen ja, wenn da Studie dransteht, dann hat das irgendwie in den äh in den.
Medienrelevanz.
Den Medien relevant.
Auch in der Politik gegebenenfalls unter Umständen vielleicht.
Genau, also wird häufig äh das also geht zurück aufn MPI, die haben irgendwie ein Tool Glas Nost, mit dem sie irgendwie geschaut haben, wie sich Traffic verhält über verschiedene Provider. Das Ding sammelt irgendwie so vor sich hin.
DP hast du gesagt.
Da gibt's also eine Seite die Info wo man sich diese Messergebnisse anschauen kann in Deutschland sieht es so aus das Kabel Deutschland vor allem,
ausbremst. Das ist aber auch schon seit längerem bekannt. Also nicht viel Neues bei rausgekommen, aber.
Ähm mal belegt.
Schöne Studie, auf die man dann verweisen kann. Kommen auch noch ein paar Links zu, wie man sich selber an solchen Messungen beteiligen kann. Und was ich, glaube ich, bei der Gelegenheit auch,
schon mal erwähnt hatte, ist dieses Respekt my net,
ähm geht so ein bisschen auf die Lackfader Türleute, unter anderem zurück, wo äh man auch dazu angehalten ist, Netzneutralitätsverstöße bei sich selber zu messen und dann dort zu melden.
So, was haben wir denn Neues bei unserem Lieblingsthema Vorratsdatenspeicherung?
Ja äh da haben wir eigentlich auch nur eine kurze Meldung und zwar bietet der äh Friedrich.
Der Innenminister.
Der Friedrich, der äh Herr Innen, der IM Friedrich ähm.
Er hat sich großzügig bereit erklärt, äh jetzt doch mal äh irgendwie ein Kompromiss,
mit dem mit der Bundesjustizministerin anzustreben.
Und irgendwie äh auf eine Novellierung dieser Vorratsdatenspeicherungsrichtlinie hinzuarbeiten. Hat aber dann trotzdem natürlich irgendwie noch den den,
den Appell dadrin, dass ja die Strafzahlung drohen und so also hat sich eigentlich nicht nicht viel gezeigt. Es,
Ich erwähne das deshalb, weil ich ja, glaube in der letzten Sendung, bei der wir uns damit auseinandergesetzt haben, noch betont hatte, dass er ja
derjenige war, der da so so streng und unnachgiebig war und ähm zeigt sich tatsächlich, dass äh,
dass sich das nun auch in seinem Handeln niederschlägt. Aber sonst gibt's ja eigentlich nichts Neues.
Okay.
Korrektur gab's zu unseren Aussagen der Problematik, die der Entwickler von Insta Cast mit äh mit der Flatterintegration im Kontext äh iOS App Store hat.
Genau. Ich glaube, da ging's darum, dass ich irgendwie ähm,
Gesagt habe, dass alles irgendwie durch äh Apple gehen muss und da hat uns der Martin von geschrieben, dass die die Regeln von Apple sind, dass wenn man Spenden,
über die App verteilen möchte, die nur über Safari oder SMS gesammelt werden dürfen.
Und außerdem müssen Apps die Spenden sammeln, kostenlos sein. Das ist also ähm.
Weil das sind quasi die zwei Regeln, gegen die er verstößt. Der bietet eine eine Bezahl-App an, die Spenden verteilt, verstoß eins und diese Spenden werden weder über Safari noch über SMS verteilt. Und ähm.
Quasi der Vorwurf der Implizite, die implizite Annahme, die ich da reingestellt habe, ist Apple an den Spenden mitverdienen möchte.
Ja, wobei, ob er dagegen verstößt, ist nicht festgestellt worden, ja, sondern es ist lediglich.
Grade die Frage.
Und holt und und das gilt es eben zu klären, weil man ja genauso auch argumentieren kann, dass er an der Stelle das Geld ja gar nicht,
Dadurch fließt, ja. Ist ein schwieriger Bereich, weil es ja mehr so eine Parametrisierung eines eines Auszahlungsvorgangs ist, der ganz woanders und zu einem ganz anderen Zeitpunkt über eine ganz andere Kanäle stattfindet,
Ist einfach schwierig, ja, das äh wird sich zeigen. Ist auf jeden Fall alles noch ähm aufgeschoben.
Geh mal YouTube.
Schöne äh Sache. Da habe ich ja mal äh hm mich sehr gut sehr stark festgelegt, dass ich davon ausgehe, dass keiner von beiden
in Berufung geht, weil sich ja auch beide als Sieger gefühlt haben bei diesem angewehnten angesprochenen Urteil, ich glaub in LNP zweiundzwanzig,
glaube ich äh dargestellt. Und ähm ich sagte ja, wenn die beide sich als Sieger fühlen, werden sie auch beide nicht in Berufung gehen, weil man geht ja nicht in Berufung gegen ein äh Urteil, bei dem man sich als Sieger fühlt.
Ist aber noch besser. Es sind auch jetzt beide in Berufung gegangen, also beide haben gewonnen.
Und beide haben nicht das gekriegt, was sie wollten. Ja, das ist übrigens sehr interessant, ne, also in der Öffentlichkeit ist man einfach äh zufrieden und ist der Sieger und hintenrum haut man dann einfach weiter zu, solange, bis man alles gekriegt hat, was man schon immer haben wollte.
Ähnlich wie wie Hertha jetzt mit diesem äh Fußballspiel.
Ähm und jetzt Begründung auch da, aber wieder einleuchtend, zumindest laut äh GEMA ähm,
Laut Gamer PM, dass sie nach dem Urteil zurück an den Verhandlungstisch gegangen sind, aber die Berufungsfrist ist ja relativ kurz. Du hast ja nur eine bestimmte Zeit äh Berufung einzulegen. Und haben gesagt, na ja, es sieht ein bisschen danach aus,
Oder wir wollen nicht riskieren, dass die Berufungsfrist abläuft und wir da an den Tisch hängen und dann ist dieses Urteil da und dann sind wir am Ende doch nicht wieder damit zufrieden.
Und laut Gamer von YouTube habe ich da keine offizielle, vernünftige Verlautbarung zugefunden. Laut GEMA ist YouTube nicht bereit, die Ergebnisse der Verhandlungen offen zu legen
wo ich da dabei gehe ich davon aus, dass da dran drin stünde, was weiß ich, welche welche Preise da gezahlt werden. Und es ist ja in der Tat so, dass YouTube da äh nicht,
Offiziell irgendwie das nicht so ganz klar ist, weil das natürlich auch in verschiedenen Ländern, die wollen natürlich nicht ihre Verhandlungspositionen irgendwie für die über hundert Länder der Welt schwächen, bei denen sie das noch nicht gemacht haben.
Und ähm,
quasi also die die äh YouTube sagt, wenn wir mit euch eine Einigung finden, dann wollen wir nicht, dass irgendwo steht, wie viel wir euch zahlen. Und die GEMA sagt, na ja, ähm wir sind rechtlich zur Veröffentlichung verpflichtet.
Wir müssen sagen, was wir da kriegen,
und das scheint also jetzt da, dass das Problem zu sein, wenn ich diese Gamer Pressemitteilung richtig deute. Man muss allerdings dazu sagen, dass die,
diese Pressemitteilung eventuell nicht hundertprozentig,
sauber formuliert ist, weil der ist auch sehr schöner, der findet sich dieser Satz drin nach dem erstinstanzlichen Urteil kann YouTube die Rechte
nicht mehr einfach nur auf das von YouTube eingerichtet. Content Verifizierungsverfahren verweisen. Die angebotenen Musikwerte müssen darüber hinaus,
Fingerprints bestückt werden. Was ich so wie, wie bestückst du denn ein, ein, ein Musikstück mit einem Fingerprint, also.
Musikstück ist doch sein eigener Finger.
Musikstück ist ein Fingerprint, ja, also so der Fingerprint wird da okay, alles klar, brauchen wir nicht.
Menschen, Menschen müssen jetzt auch nachträglich mit Fingerabdrücken ausgestattet.
Ja genau, Menschen müssen, außerdem müssen die Fingerabdrücke kriegen, ja. Ferner muss YouTube zukünftig ein Wortfilter einsetzen,
auch das ist natürlich nicht so, also das trifft auch nicht so einhundert Prozent zu, ne? Also ein Wortfilter ähm andererseits finde ich es auch witzig, dass die GEMA das irgendwie als Erfolg feiert, weil Wortfilter ist nun wirklich kein äh,
Wort.
Wortfilter im Sinne von der Beschreibung Titel.
Ja, ja. Das, also da ging's ja darum, dass äh dass dass YouTube auch das,
Als Anhaltspunkt nehmen soll, wie man diesen Titel dann eben nimmt oder so. Ähm aber wie gesagt,
Wenn man sich überlegt, dass da Menschen, die die PM schreiben, die glauben, dass man irgendwie in einer Dateien einen Fingerprint dranklebt, dann weiß ich nicht, wie wie ordentlich die den Streitpunkt des Gerichtsverfahrens darstellen konnten.
Auf jeden Fall, beide, beide gehen in Berufung und ähm wir werden sehen, es bleibt also spannend.
Genau, bleibt spannend und wir bleiben aber trotzdem noch ein bisschen im Themenbereich, denn da gab's eine Ideenvorstellung auf der Sigind.
Ja und zwar wurde da die C.
3S vorgestellt.
C3S vorgestellt. Ähm.
Da muss man zu sagen, also es gibt im Moment ein ein Problem für für einen Musiker, der sich also entscheidet, irgendwie ein Musikstück zu veröffentlichen unter Creative Commons Lizenz.
Wenn man bei der GEMA ist, kann man das eigentlich nicht machen,
weil die der Gamer-Vertrag eine künstlerbezogene Lizenzierung ist, der Künstler ist einfach bei der GEMA Punkt,
und die Lizenz eine werksbasierte Lizenzierung ist. Und die sind ähm.
Wenn ich das richtig verstehe, ist es inkompatibel und nicht möglich für einen Gamer-Künstler äh CC.
Überhaupt irgendwas, äh da irgendeiner anderen Lizenz als das, wie man das hat, zu veröffentlichen.
Ja, also ist auf jeden Fall unvereinbar. Ich frage mich jetzt nicht, was genau passiert, wenn er es jetzt doch macht. Ähm,
Ich glaube, dann ist er quasi sein eigener Vertreiber oder so. Also es geht auf jeden Fall nicht. Die die beiden Lizenzmodelle sind inkompatibel. Und ähm das ist auch,
Das wurde bei der vorletztes Jahr,
relativ ausführlich erklärt, ähm was ich mir davon gemerkt habe, ist, äh ist inkompatibel und geht eben nicht.
Vituell ist. Das ist eine Musik orientierte Konferenz, die hier in Berlin stattfindet, seitdem die.
Berlin Music Week so ein bisschen angekürzt wurde, oder?
Ne, es begann doch mit dem Ausfall der Popcorn.
Ach ja, genau, genau.
Hat ja mal äh es nicht auf die Reihe bekommen und hat man ja Pause gemacht und dann sind alle gleich in die Lücke gesprungen und seitdem hat sich das jetzt so als Begleit äh Wald zu der Veranstaltung etabliert.
Genau, ich suche das mal noch raus, ob ich da den Link auch zu dieser Veranstaltung finde. Auf jeden Fall das ist so bisschen der der äh der Ausgangszustand.
Aber was wollen die denn dann kollekten?
Ich meine, wenn's keine Abgaben gibt, in dem also keine oder geht's hier wirklich dadrum, mal Einnahmen zu schaffen und die dann auch.
Also ich glaube, es geht.
Zu verteilen oder geht's nur dadrum, eine Alternative zu GEMA zu haben, um zu sagen, äh ihr seid nicht die Einzigen, die sich für Werte ein äh einsetzen und von daher kann eure Annahme, dass alles, was äh,
veröffentlicht wird automatisch erstmal unter GEMA-Feld nicht mehr gehalten werden?
Also muss man nochmal kurz also,
Punkt eins ist, Lizenzen sind nicht mit der Gamer vereinbar. Punkt zwei ist, dass Urheberrecht ist seit so vielen Jahren so,
fest zementiert, dass es eigentlich aussichtslos ist, ernsthaft davon auszugehen, dass man dann nennenswerte Änderungen dran,
erreichen kann. Ich glaube du hattest das ja in einem Chaos-Radio Express mit dem Matthias Spielkamp auch mal so herausgearbeitet, dass ja äh es relativ schwierig ist, Leuten,
Rechte, die sie haben,
wegzunehmen. Das heißt, wenn wir heute ein Urheberrecht haben, was sagt, da ist Recht, gilt, siebzig Jahre bis nach deinem Tod. Und wir schaffen das heute ab, dann müssen wir warten, bis der letzte Urheber stirbt. Plus siebzig Jahre,
bis wir quasi die Altlast des Urheberrechts vollständig entfernt haben aus unserer, aus unserer, ja,
und das ist also das zweite Problem, weshalb ähm.
Auch ein verdammt gutes verdammt guter Grund wäre tatsächlich mal eine Änderung einzuführen, insbesondere, weil sie sich dann erst so spät.
Bis zu hundertvierzig Jahre sein, wenn man jetzt einen ganz jungen Urheber hat. So, Justin Bieber oder so.
Ja, man kann auch demnächst noch sehr viel älter werden, wenn sich das so weiter entwickelt mit der Lebenserwartung. Also das ist ja alles kontrapro.
Also keiner kann sich noch lange dauern. So und das sind also die beiden Ausgangspunkte, warum jetzt äh der, wie heißt der denn?
Heike, ne, hingeht und ein ein anderes Modell äh sich vorzuschlagen, anschickt.
Und aus diesen äh,
genau, es nennt sich dann die Society, C3S, die ihr dann irgendwie die Idee wieder irgendwie patentieren oder was
und das soll dann ein ein alternativ Modell zur GEMA sein. Und ihr sagt also genau diese Kulturwerkmarkt oder sonstwas Kulturwerk Marktmodelle
oder Piratenparteiansätze sind einfach nicht so, würden nicht so schnell eine Möglichkeit herbeiführen. Und er sagt, er möchte dann also einen Kompromiss verfolgen mit diesem,
C drei S. Ähm und zwar soll das nichtkommenzielle Tauschen ähm,
erlaubt sein und die Künstler sollen trotzdem angemessen angemessen vergütet werden ähm und es soll irgendwie hauptsächlich so Lizenzen basiert sein.
Ähm und quasi so eine Abstufungshiarchie äh steht, dahinter steht, wie man ein Werk weiterverarbeiten darf äh und äh wie nicht,
ähm wie er sich das jetzt einhundert Prozent ähm im im Detail vorstellt, äh sehe ich,
Allerdings auch noch nicht zu einhundert Prozent. Ähm.
Es ist ja ohnehin irgendwie so, ich hatte das ja erwähnt, dass das Problem ist, äh dass die.
Das das ist eben für diesen ganzen freien Kram noch nicht so wirklich das Verwertungsmodell,
gibt und die Beispiele jener Künstler, die mit reich geworden sind, äh leider noch nicht so zahlreich sind. Und mit dieser äh C drei S wird äh dieses Problem versucht anzugehen.
Deswegen ist das eine ähm eine interessante, ein interessanter Ansatz, auf den ihr mal ähm verwiesen sei.
Verwiesen sei. Gut. Bei Logbuch, die fünfundzwanzigste Ausgabe.
Die Siegin insgesamt war durchaus ergebnisreich, so im Gespräch, fand ich.
Im Gespräch war es unglaublich ergebens, weil ich fand das sehr schön. Ich habe mich total gefreut da äh sehr viele freundliche Menschen zu treffen und äh auch kennenzulernen. Ähm,
Ich hoffe, dass ich da nicht manchmal den Eindruck gemacht habe, äh irgendwie keinen Bock mehr zu haben oder unfreundlich zu sein, weil ich äh dann doch auch ein bisschen sehr müde war zwischenzeitlich. Ähm.
Dafür hast du aber lange durchgehalten.
Deswegen war ich ja dann auch müde,
und äh freundlicherweise dann äh mit sehr viel Mate auch im Laufe des Tages versorgt wurde, ähm das war also alles eine, eine sehr nette Sache. Was ich sehr schön fand, war, dass es,
Einerseits so familiär war wie Republica.
Andererseits aber noch ein bisschen kleiner, was es noch familiärer gemacht hat und dann aber so ein bisschen mehr ähm Hacker wieder dabei waren.
Hat dir das gefehlt.
Bei der nee hat mir das nicht wirklich gefehlt, aber ich mag halt Hacker, ich bin gerne mit Hackern zusammen so.
Und man hatte ein bisschen ähm wirklich so ein bisschen,
schöne Ruhe, also wie gesagt, jetzt hat man ja schon gehört, sich mal einfach ausführlich, dann sind wir die Staatstrojaner zu unterhalten. Das ist dann bei bei größeren Veranstaltungen wie Kongress oder Republika
doch eher in dem Ausmaß, wie wir das dann da mal gemacht haben, nicht möglich.
Gut, dann würde ich sagen, beenden wir mal hier diese heißere Kurzversion von Lokbuchnetzpolitik. Ja, und hoffen wir, was wir nächste Woche wieder ein bisschen mehr Stimme haben.
Du, meine Stimme ist einwandfrei. Ich weiß nicht, äh mal gucken, wie meine nächste Woche.
Ich wollte das jetzt so ein bisschen verallgemeinern, aber stimmt schon. Ich hoffe, dass meine Stimme bald wieder ertönen kann. Okay.
Alles klar, auf Wiederhören.
Bis bald, tschüss.